[Music]
this had better be good
[Music]
hello and welcome to PlayStation granade
Ubisoft have officially revealed the
next watchdogs game at e3 2019 to
celebrate the unveiling
I have teamed up with Ubisoft to tell
you nine things you need to know about
watchdogs Legion and believe me there
are some impressive innovations coming
and as this is a sponsored video we have
our own custom link in the description
below where you can find out more about
Legion including the pre-order bonuses
such as the golden king pack but we'll
get to that very soon let's break down
watchdogs Legion with some exclusive
unseen footage to welcome to the
resistance
[Music]
let's start with the biggest innovation
that watchdogs Legion gives us if you're
expecting a gritty generic hero with a
shady past and grizzled voice then get
that out of your head the main character
is anyone you see in the world anyone at
all just sit back and take that in for a
second every single NPC can be your
protagonist if you choose them to be so
NPCs no longer stand for non playable
characters in watchdogs legion let's
call them newly playable characters if
you want to play as a bare-knuckle boxer
go for it
maybe a Bobby on the beat that's a
police officer by the way if you can
find them they are yours to play us you
already know that I'm gonna go for the
big guns the oldest person in the game
this Nana she will be my hero the
deadliest of the love she's experienced
let's quickly take a step back and look
at Legion setting it's none other than
bloody landed London greatest city in
the world I'm sure you've already
figured that out by the amount of times
we say bloody and mate and the freedoms
are bloody joke bloody machines on your
feet mate buddy check one bloody drives
are everywhere
another thing I'm sure you're aware of
is that the UK is attempting to break
away from the European Union which acts
as the basis of the story imagining the
worst possible scenario from that point
and that brings us to watchdogs Legion
now as a right mess
governments flowed off London is now a
surveillance state our freedoms have
been replaced with this crippling fear
of the establishment in a multicultural
society the deportation squads are now
Judge Judy and executioner not to
mention the organized crime underworld
it's time for the locals to stand up and
take the power back
it's all of us together the way those
two elements come together make up the
potential brilliance of watchdogs Legion
not only will we be able to choose our
character we will live and die in the
city there is perma death in this game
maybe after an hour maybe after ten
hours your character could die
what happens next well we are given a
fleeting chance to continue with playing
as that character lots of time but once
they pass away they are gone for good
forever rest in peace after that happens
we fill the shoes of another dead SEC
operative instantly moving forward
without your fallen comrade
although they do make reference to those
that pass away wait what happened to
that bloke who helped me he didn't make
it as we play through our focus will be
to expand our forces recruiting new
operatives we will build the resistance
and take back London here's something
which blew my mind any NPC can be
recruited they all have voice actors a
thought-out backstory with different
motivations they even have an origin
story to play through before they become
a member of the resistance you think
everyone else has given up and there's
no one to trust that's what they want
you to think and that's how they'll take
us one at a time it doesn't have to be
that way together we can change things
each character has a subtly different
skillset meaning selecting a punk-rocker
a schoolteacher or even an mi5 agent can
be hugely beneficial but come on we all
want to play as that 90 year old right
yeah I'm sure we'll go for the military
badass instead
they can get anywhere and erase any one
I personally need to make sure I don't
keep deliberately murdering my character
to see who pops up next I wonder if it's
possible to complete the game in a
single life with a single character and
by having permadeath in the game by
losing that one character you've been
playing as for the last 30 hours we'll
all on our heartstrings it will be
heartbreaking to lose them and they
ain't coming back
so don't accidentally blow yourself up
with a grenade we're talking about
recruitment every person in this
dystopian future London is a walking
chip-and-pin we can scan them all as the
on screen pop up show us their subtle
skill differences are visible 15% plus
turret damage 10% extra damage when on
low health are more important skills
like drone expertise or links to their
addictions one guy is addicted to
adrenaline I can't see him lasting very
long this allows us to prep for missions
and choose the perfect operative I doubt
Helen the elderly lady can scale a
building we get down rice I'd love to
see a try this type of control and
customization will be an important
element in watchdogs Legion open your
eyes and take a look around
a few people including myself was a
little worried that watchdogs in the UK
would mean no over-the-top action pieces
you know like him queuing up for
drinking tea I mean like guns we all
thought that because the UK has quite a
strict gun law that they won't be in the
game well let's clear that up right now
watchdogs Legion is packed with guns
bombs and other ways to take down the
system the same thing goes for
cutting-edge technology which makes
watchdogs watch dogs CTOs remains
pivotal to hacking infiltrating with
those killer drones there's even a few
oversized ones to fly around on this is
due to drawn technology being used for
pretty much everything in this world
from delivery services to heavy lifting
on construction sites meaning we can
literally hack a drone flight to our
current location hop on board and fly
any
pretty damn cool our my personal
favorite must be the scuttling spider
robots of death that's a pretty good way
to die although we haven't seen the full
extent of the game world we have been
given access to long shots of the city
and if we use the Skyrim rule ie where
ever you can see you can visit then that
would mean this map is bloody huge we
are also able to confirm many tourist
spots will be accessible Big Ben that's
the Bell inside the clock tower tower
bridge not to be confused with London
Bridge the houses of parliament to the
Gherkin Chinatown we could go on and on
if the game uses history as a starting
point we could see this new revolution
pick up the pieces of Guy Fawkes and his
attempt to bring down the controlling
factions of the city known as the
Gunpowder Plot I wonder if his mask
though you know the one used in V for
Vendetta
is in here somewhere as I'm throwing out
ideas what about stealing the crown
jewels
I would likely be hung drawn and
quartered for suggesting that but I
would love to get my hands on Lizzie's
bits and pieces I am definitely going to
prison for saying that let's move on is
now a good time to bring up the language
have you noticed we live in a time where
shooting people is okay but foul
languages are no-no in video games
always show those government's filmed
off kicking our teeth in lately oh you
are um done now
well watchdogs Legion may have the most
sweary video game in Ubisoft history and
to be honest it's the most London thing
about the game
never mind the beautiful recreation of
the world with hyper realistic landmarks
now it's all about the over-the-top
swearing always show those didn't we
which I can confirm is everywhere in
London you've in bellend so release date
when does watchdogs Legion release 2020
March the 6th to be precise so not long
at all like his commonplace these days
pre-order incentives are in place if you
want to see them for yourselves the link
is down below but pre-ordering now Nets
you the golden King pack a pure gold
weapon skin a luxury golden vehicle wrap
and a regal mask to keep your identity
protected in the game for those who want
more than the base game the gold
ultimate and collector's editions have
three days of early access to show off
to your friends and they all include the
season pass which once again confirms
Ubisoft commitment to support and
improve the game for months and years to
come I honestly can't think of another
organization who has this uncanny
ability to improve games year upon year
rainbow succeeds the division for honor
all these games have continually
innovated and pushed forward so the
season pass will hopefully see watchdogs
legion follow that same trend o also
look at this collector's edition a
highly detailed mask from the game
goddamnit I need and I don't know why
there's also so many things that each
edition has so it's probably best for
you to check for yourselves and you
should do that anyway as occasionally
different regions of the world receive
different content and extras so the link
is in the description so that's where we
currently stand with watchdogs legion so
let's open a dialogue I'd love to know
your thoughts on Legion what impresses
you
what reservations do you have and what
questions would you like me to
constantly annoy their PR reps with I
have to say the mechanics of changing
character and seeing how their life has
been affected by the organized crime and
the system that they live within has me
very excited for this game and also what
will happen in cutscenes with different
characters I wonder if the 80 year old
granny can do parkour these are random
questions that just pop into my head
sometimes anyway if you've got this fire
in the video please accept my thanks I
do appreciate it and also a little quiz
question who would win in a fight
between Aiden Pearce from the original
watchdogs
Marcus Holloway from watchdogs 2 and
that lovely grandma that I can't get out
of my head from Legion you know who my
money's on if I imagine for a
Playstation grenade it's been a pleasure
I'll see you next time
[Music]